Oh Jennifer is this me this is yes sit
down join us welcome which one salmon
which ones yeah that's she buy anything
for both of us I'm Sam and that's Jim
but it's not polite that she wants she
knows who I am she's you know what
before you came in Jim said that you
guys used to date so it's weird that you
don't even know who raised you well
thank you for confirming I can't hear
myself in my ears you have to turn the
things up when I go into Family Guy I
make them turn the volume way way up
do you like to hear yourself or no I
love to hear myself just to prove that I
exist
oh my do voiceover auditions you know
you can enter your phone sure on your
phone but I can't I'm really horrible
because I don't hear myself in my ears
and it's just I sound like a kid doing
like a radio show do you do it in the
car in the closet and I have a big
built-in closet I'll go in there and do
my voiceovers and read it and it's
that's what she said she said Mike
that's when my voiceover agent said she
said it's good if there's hanging
clothes cause it muffles ambient sound
but I don't know it just seems like I've
never gotten anything that I've done the
voiceovers either way yeah I think you
need to go in the studio and you know
feel all professional like people know
what you sound like though at this point
like you're a very distinct voice I do
but my voice changes a lot like when I
play Tiffany I talk like this Jackie
we belong dad know when I played like a
sultry person I talk like this thing hi
honey how are you doing so I have like
different sort of way that's the
Jennifer I like yeah I don't remember
dating you I'm sure it was really good
yeah so when you go into a closet and
you do it you listen back to it like
I'll listen back for a second like I'm
too close I hate myself I hate how I
love how I sound in them in the
headphones but I don't have they have I
get so frustrated and then I told my
voiceover agent si
don't send me any voiceovers and Lissa's
for a lot of money because I just get so
angry I hate I sound I spent two or
three hours doing the voice-over you
know the the audition it's basically
they want what they watch are you sure
they're listening to
a lot of people and it's like after two
syllables they know if they want me or
not I feel like I'm just spinning my
wheels but I hate to listen to myself
and so it's like I feel like I have to
get a studio built I want a studio built
sort of like this one in my guesthouse
where I can have you know push some
buttons and put a little reverb on and
you know maybe a little ambient music or
something sure I think I'll NAB one of
those big commercials well you sound so
different like when you do like when
you're going in for ADR when you're
doing something like in the studio know
that when you're in there in the
different room than you are and it's
just you with the music stand in front
you sound so much different and base
here than you're talking into your
iPhone you have I can't like get no
indication of what I'm gonna sound yeah
when I talk into my iPhone my voice
sounds very very thin and then also to a
star and I get like oh this house
horrible like right in the middle of it
I have like so much self-loathing yeah I
click like erase delete and they're like
oh she wanted to leave them like yes
yeah delete now yeah it's just too easy
like you end up doing it over and over
and over again because it's too easy to
just delete it right there yeah well are
you filled with self-doubt myself down
do you have a lot of that you know
Janeane Garofalo I think a production
company was called I hate myself
productions and I was like oh my god I
know exactly what she's talking about
but um no I don't you know they say I
can see here people you know women call
like oh my god ever since I hit my 40
life really began and you know I'm so
much happier now and I'm you know in my
20s I was like well yeah I mean what
would they say I mean you kind of gotta
make the best of a bad situation but
actually I love where I am right now
like I feel so good about myself good
and I don't really have a lot of
self-doubt at all like I feel like I can
do anything you know when I want to
after I finish taking my nap right I'm
really I'm really lazy like in the last
few years I feel like well I'm just
hibernating and you know when I get the
energy I'm gonna do that really great
big important thing that I've always
been planning to do so when did you
start to gain confidence like that at
what point in your life or career
whatever I would say maybe about 10
years ago I started getting very
involved in poker and I love right
playing poker you're dating a poker girl
yes Phil Laak he's known as a Unabomber
sure sure you jealous no no I played
poker i mastered it and i stopped
are you jealous that phil laak is the
once it's obviously dated you forgot all
about you are you jealous
phil now this is really wonderful woman
we had a great time together
[Laughter]
dating for luck you guys been together
for we've been together for 14 years
Wow and did he get you totally in a
poker I'm drinking some tea now let me
finish drinking my tea and then I will
take your time okay okay well I actually
met him at a poker game it was called
the celebrity Invitational is where
celebrities and poker players play
together in harmony
and I was like wow I just really love
this poker thing and I was very filled
with hubris I thought it was like the
most amazing poker player ever like I
wasn't like those other celebrities that
thought they played poker I knew I
really really was good at poker so I
busted out the training about four and a
half minutes so then I wandered around
like bothering all the poker players cuz
I thought it would be really great to
have a poker player as a buddy and we
could go to the Commerce Casino and we
could play like all baller like so that
was I really that intention in my head
like I'm gonna meet a poker player and
he's gonna take me around to the casino
we're gonna play together and I met Phil
and he wasn't one of the guys I had in
mind because you know some of the poker
players they were very suave bollo and
you know just like more James Bondy in
Philly I don't know if you're familiar
with him but in in you know the radio
world but he's super goofy I mean he's
very famous he went when he won the
celebrity Invitational he was like
shadow boxing and doing push-ups and you
know doing all this bad behavior and it
started all these editorials like should
people behave like that in poker so he
sort of ushered in the new era like
McEnroe in tennis yeah well no no Phil
Hellmuth is like McEnroe in tennis he's
like they called the poker brat
he has tantrums when he loses and he
stands up and breaks he other people for
their bad play they're not out of the
tournament I played with him before -
he's actually a really nice guy but he
gets right up phil is really he's the
kind of guy like I would say if somebody
did
a survey of who do you want most want at
your home poker game he's the guy you
want at your home poker game because
he's really goofy and easygoing and very
[ __ ]
when you date so part of being a poker
player obviously is the bluffing and the
whole no one knows what you're thinking
so as a person at home is it difficult
to read him or is that just a thing he
can do any place cards I can read Phil
very well because he's my boyfriend you
know you guys he when you have the
girlfriends and the wives and everything
they always know what you're up to
so don't don't fool yourself and think
like oh they don't know I was out with
the guys last night you know at the
strip joint they know they're there
either choosing not to say anything or
they're being very passive-aggressive
and you know sort of pretending like
they don't know and you can't um you
don't know what are you upset about
always nobody's done I won like I kind
of can pick up his Tallis just cuz I
know him so well and I'm not gonna say
what they are but we try not to play at
the same table
you know because Phil says it's a no-win
situation to me is I'm very competitive
like I love when I knock fill out or
take a big pot off of him except for you
know kind of the fallout but he says I
hate when I take a big pot off of you
and I hate when you take a big pot off
of me and then if we saw play each other
then it was like oh you two are
colluding he says there's no way to win
but I mean I don't mind if Phil knocks
me out of a tournament or takes a big
pot off of me and I don't mind if I take
a pot off of him but I do I don't like
when people are like oh you two your
soft playing each other which we do not
do we hardly even feel light about them
he doesn't hate taking a part of you he
hates when you take one off him because
that'd be like if you guys weren't out
for like if he kept getting auditions
that you weren't getting right you'd be
right what the [ __ ] is he doing this is
my it is really true when I first came
out to LA I was dating an actor in his
ten years older than me is very good
actor and it took me like four years to
get my first part and my first part was
it was a television series called Boone
and it was like kind of the Elvis
Presley story it only lasted one season
that was a girlfriend that's too much
information no it's not that's great to
know but I remember I came home one day
and I was upset because the director or
something had happened on the set I was
like you know I was very young I was in
my 20 and I called it my boyfriend who
was in his 30s and he yelled at me he
goes at least you have a job and he hug
oh my god I don't know this actor on
actor thing is gonna work out and you
know I've seeded a lot of actors in my
lifetime and I think it's better actor
and poker player I think that's a really
good combination did you take Michaelmas
formula I did not date him I did a movie
with him and I loved working with him
and yes it's right together I did two
movies with him we had great chemistry
and we had such a fun time making the
Galloway I was like I sometimes say it's
like the best show on location shoot I
ever had cuz we were like I don't know
we're in Arizona or the Midwest we were
shooting we're in these really small
towns the whole crew would go out every
single night to these honky tonks and we
would where we buy cowboy hats and
turquoise and it was sort of like it was
kind of like the idea of what it is like
to be on a film set but yeah he's really
funny he's got a great sense of humor
he's very politically incorrect you know
you know sometimes he says stuff and
you're like look around before you laugh
you want to make sure nobody hears you
laughing at this joke but you know he's
kind of he's incorrigible that's what he
is I was watching an early interview of
yours on Johnny Carson show I mean I say
one thing about Michael Munson that I
think is interesting when he was doing
this movie he was supposed to be the
John Travolta part in Pulp Fiction
they actually written that to be like
what is the character in Reservoir Dogs
Vinny he was supposed to be it was
supposed to be that character in
Reservoir Dogs and Quentin Tarantino was
like please I wrote this part for you
but he said he didn't want to be the bad
guy also - every single day the
producers were coming and they want him
to be the Kevin Bacon character well
wait who didn't want to be the bad guy
Madsen Madsen he said he said I want to
get typecast as the bad guy so he did
Free Willy instead and that's what
renovated John Travolta's career I
rejuvenated it Wow he also turned down
the part the Kevin Bacon partner River
while and isn't the character in John
Travolta's character in Pulp Fiction is
his brother yeah yeah but it was
actually that character but you know
he's gone on to do a lot of Quentin
Tarantino movies so you know Quentin
Tarantino did not all the Graduate
please talk to me about free will he was
generous yes well you know what it's
really funny because he says when people
it's really funny when moms with their
little kids
they see me coming the mom grabs the kid
and tries to run away cuz they think I'm
the guy that cut off the ear and the
little kid is going towards me it's like
it's the dad and frequently I go out
with him to restaurants and stuff and
little kids would come in the car you
free willies daddy and go yes that I am
he loves kids he's like you want a
picture so yeah so I guess he
accomplished his objective of not being
nasty person all the time but he's
usually a nasty person yes since then
he's kind of been a nasty person a lot
yeah but if it doesn't fit ain't broke
don't fix it right so you'll get to talk
to me about Chinese gonna ask well I was
watching it and I was kind of getting
annoyed because I felt like he wasn't
giving you anything I felt like you were
like giving giving giving and he was
just kind of sitting there okay this is
a story with Johnny Carson like when I
the first time I was on Johnny loved me
and I loved doing him and I would do a
Johnny Carson sort of like a Marilyn
Monroe II thing and you come in with
half a joke and he'd take the joke and
he rap you know he'd wrap it all up like
in a package and hand it back to you
like a fully-formed Joe so all you do is
come in with sort of attitude and idea
and then he you know would make a joke
out of it you think he's a consummate
talk-show host it's really strange to me
that now people kind of they don't
remember Johnny Carson like he was to me
he's like a giant a giant in the field
so he used to call all the time any time
a guest would fall out he'd be like she
can Jennifer come in and my husband at
the time he was like you don't want to
be the girl you don't be like the Matney
lady you don't want to be the person
this had a hundred Johnny Carson
appearances and I'm like why not
because Sam was saying like well you're
a very serious actress you don't want to
just be in there going to be a goof so I
would only go when I had something to
promote but I was very naive like you
were turning Carson down yeah a lot Wow
I didn't want to be the Johnny Carson
girl but you know Sam my ex-husband said
you don't want to be the Johnny Carson
girl but you know wasn't comedian I was
an actress so like comedians that's like
the Holy Grail but then that one show
that you saw yeah it's really funny it
was the last show that I did and I went
in and I was so used to him always
making the jokes like I would never do
the punchline he would always do the
punchline and he had had a terrible show
first of all John Larroquette was on
he's usually a great cast but he was
doing
a show where he played an alcoholic so
it wasn't the funny funny congenial John
Merrow cat it was a very serious John
lower Laurel Kenneth that was had just
done a very serious you know sort of
connecting to the character Emmy worthy
yeah so he that that's that had not gone
so well and then a magician came on you
know Johnny loves magicians and the
magician did some sort of thing that
bomb he did like uh a trick that didn't
really worked very well so by the time I
came out he was ready to go home he was
already on the bus on the way home or in
his car I'm sure he doesn't de carbón
and I went out there and I was wearing
like this little sort of it was the 80s
us wearing you know the Madonna core
city and her wear lingerie is outerwear
and I remember the guy stuck at the
Johnny Carson guy I think mr. McCauley
stuck is he and he goes I join your love
it he's gonna love your outfit you hava
you know he'll have fun with it so I win
and I did a little half a joke and I
looked at him and he didn't finish the
joke and then I did another half a joke
and I looked at him his eyes were
totally blank he was totally not there
and I felt kind of like the little kid
when the dad has a stroke and she's like
three years old yes it takes a wheel
you're jumping out of the plane in the
parachute instructor you know the guy
that you're thinking is gonna you know
pull the cord passes out he was not
there yes so all of a sudden in this is
where evolved like the jennifer Tilly
you know today they just will not shut
up on the air I turned into this whole
different character where I just started
talking I was I did and I was like I was
like I have to save myself I have to
save myself
I remember one I was talking about my
voice instructor and she was like you
have a problem with your voice and I
said and then she pulled out
she pulled something out guess what it
was and all he had to say is anything he
could say an ostrich a Volkswagen
whatever all you had to say is something
get a big laugh and he looked at me
really blank then he goes I have no idea
so anyway afterwards my people got my
peeps it all it's really bad and they're
like Johnny's not happy it was really
bad it was bad appearance and everyone's
all somber like it was a funeral and I
was like oh and they go and then they
said one of the guys said your outfit he
thought was inappropriate you came out
and like a bustier and I was like -
Macaulay City loved it he was thrown by
your outfit and then and then the next
day apparently people came in they said
oh their show was so boring I almost
turned it off and then Jennifer Tilly
came in and it was really funny so then
you start getting all these accolades
and their dick publicist said he wants
you to come in day after tomorrow but I
was really spooked because it was the
first time I'd had what I thought was a
bad show after how many how many was
that in and then Jimmy broken I was my
bus was doing The Tracey Ullman Show at
the time he goes oh yeah sometimes you
have to save yourself he said I saw your
show and I go Johnny wasn't there he
goes yeah once in a while you have to
save yourself you know he's a stand-up
comedians warm-up God so anyway I was
meaning to come back a condo oh I'll
come back when I have something to
promote my like mantra and then all of a
sudden he announced he was going off the
air and now everybody's coming in to say
goodbye to him and you know Bette Midler
when anything the show so all these a
a-list guests and you know I was like oh
it's Bulow's he listed that one I hadn't
done really anything I was on like Hill
Street Blues or whatever so I was like
the person he would call in when he
didn't have anybody and now everybody
wanted to come and say goodbyes so I
never got to say goodbye to him and I
felt like really sound about that and
then like years later like 20 years
later I was at the palm and a waiter
came up to me and he said he said Johnny
used to come in all the time and he see
you know after show went down he seemed
kind of sad and once I went up to him
and I said you know one of my you know I
really like to watch on your show is
jennifer Tilly and she said he lit out
but he said jennifer Tilly she was one
of my favorite gasps so I felt like it
was a voice from beyond the grave saying
look I felt bad about our last episode
and then the ironic thing is that's the
only episode that the including best of
Carson so that's the one that's on
YouTube on YouTube it's everywhere
and what's on best of Carson cuz they
think he realized and they say I think
he thought like oh that was a bad
appearance cuz he didn't do any jokes
but then he realized no it was a funny
appearance because it was just funny but
you know what I loved him and I've been
on a lot of great talk shows and I think
Johnny was the best there's never gonna
be another Johnny Carson
I agree did you ever get did you ever
speak to him outside cuz people who did
the show said that he was kind of a bit
difficult or hard to get to know outside
the show you know the Garry Shandling
show is sort of similar to what it's
like it never occurred to me that he
wouldn't anybody would make chitchat
because in between like people call oh
you know as soon as you go to commercial
he just turns off and apparently so
supposedly David Letterman does it too
but to me I like to think about the next
segment out you like to think about your
jokes or what worked and what didn't
work and and he's working on the next
segment too and also to like on you know
on film they always go like oh don't go
all out for the rehearsal save it for
camera so if you're making chitchat you
see something funny during the
commercial your sort of shot your wad
yeah so he oh okay okay now can you hear
me even okay yeah but so he did he was
not super chatty in between or before
the show or anything that he was always
very pleasant but I never expected him
to you know be like Jennifer I'm having
a great barbecue at my house next week
and why didn't you come yeah people said
they wanted to know him so badly yeah
that was never like a goal for you like
you were never like I'm gonna try to he
likes me this is like my eighth time on
the show maybe I should pursue a
personal really you get this vibe I had
this feeling that he had great affection
for me I see but the first time that I
was on the show they said they'd go oh
you know we need to do a pre-interview I
might have been my first talk show girls
like pre-interview I said you know I'm
good in front of an audience huh you
know I won't run out of stuff to say and
they go oh everyone says that but when
you get in front of Johnny Carson I Rory
said he's like the great north wind they
called him the great north wind they
said he's such a presence that people
just clam up and then then they also
said Johnny likes to go off the script
so if he goes off the script and that's
what they used to tell me with Jim
Carrey too if he goes off the script
you just get him back to the script like
I'm like I'm just a little girl I'm
supposed to be his babysitter but then
the first time I went on it was like
maybe not such a great appearance and
they were deciding whether to have me on
again and I Bob told she brought me on
the first time he was like I wasn't such
great appearance and when my publicist
trying to get me on again
they went to Jim McCauley because Bob
Dole she's saying yeah and they looked
at the tape and they said oh yeah well
we can see where she went off the script
and that part wasn't so good and they go
no that was on that that was the script
and they looked at the script they save
everything and they're like oh my god it
was the script and so they said to me
Jennifer
feel free to go off the script whenever
possible they said you're better when
you're off the script so after that I
kind of had carte blanche and you know
Johnny he he does like he likes to kind
of go with the flow you know he doesn't
like to be pinned down he was really not
sorry he was really good at just like
lobbying things up and then stepping out
of the way and like just letting people
shine absolutely he was he was great I
read that book that his lawyer wrote
yeah we interviewed him for that tub for
[ __ ] about Henry Bushkin yeah you
feel a little bit you know sort of like
well it's a little bit of invasion of
privacy but then you're very grateful to
it because I think he showed him is he
human and you know that that story about
when he went into it broke into his
ex-wife's apartment and saw a picture of
her with her her old boyfriend and sort
of fell against the wall and and was
crying you know you like oh you don't
really think of that you just remember
him making snarky jokes about how much
alimony he has to pay her and stuff so
it does humanize him also - I went to
the Marilyn Monroe auction and I was
sitting next to God was a huge Marilyn
fan and he said he met the maid that
wrote the book about it was called
Marilyn under his uncensored or under
covers or Marilyn private something
Marilyn something and it's just
basically they made telling stories
about how depressed and Marilyn was and
how she'd lie in bed like naked and eat
pork chops and like rub her not pork
chops beef ribs she'd eat ribs and like
rub her fingers on the sheets and
everything and he said to her why did
you write that book that was such a
violation you know you were privy to the
inner Marilyn and you shouldn't have
written that book but I got she wrote
that book because you know that's like
the it was like
the closest approximation to Maryland
being a human as opposed to being like
this sex you want you want to see
vulnerability in these icons so sure
yeah just so you can relate to them as
people yeah did you have to do that with
with Jim Carrey on liar liar did you
have to kind of rein him in well Jim
Carrey the thing is before I get Liar
Liar and I think I remember reading
master broader was like yeah you don't
really like didn't like working with Jim
Carrey I'm paraphrasing I don't know I
was reading about other people I kind of
understand when I work with him I loved
working with him by the way because he's
insanely creative like I'm used to doing
low-budget movies and you know you get
three or four takes have it takes this a
lot you know you get it you move on Jim
was very stiff sometimes in the earlier
takes and then also I need breakthrough
and he'd be brilliant and at the point
where everyone else would say let's move
on he was just getting started and then
he do that taken and it would be
hysterical you wouldn't think he beat
could be any fun year and then the next
take more and more like more baroque and
more curlicues and pretty soon he's like
slamming the toilet lid on his head and
stuff and so the only thing with Jim is
that they have three cameras going at
all times like even if it was my
close-up they had a camera on me a
camera a two-shot and a camera on Jim
just in case he thought of something
funny to do during my close-up the first
time that happened I was very unaware
and you know I started off to a bad
start and I was like why waste film I
was like oh I'm sorry can we start over
again
I saw Jim's face I saw everyone's face
and I was like oh my god I did not
realize it it was basically Jim scene or
that you know but he was he was very
nice to me and Tom Shadyac had worked
with him before and you understood that
you know the fires of creativity never
die a lot of people they're very
authoring the other person's close-up
but Jim gives 110% so sometimes you know
he'll think of something very funny to
say during your close-up but we were not
allowed to improvise and I loved to
improvise they would be said like if you
said to Jim for example oh did you pick
up that bread and his line is yes if he
tells like some insane story about going
down the street and they were out of
bread he ends up in Mexico and he's
being pursued by a you know then the
narcos or whatever
he finishes you cannot ask him any
follow-up questions you can't be like
what the narcos you have to say your
next line which is like great they
they're like please do not go down that
road with Jim only Jim is allowed to go
down that road and I think they thought
like you know one crazy insane genius in
a movie is enough and we were all there
to kind of support him and at the end of
the movie Oh towards the end of the
movie the cinematographer said to me
Jennifer I worked on the Gulf other
movies and we've already shot more
footage than golf either one egg off
father to put tickets oh my god at the
junket the director said to us me and
Maddy he says I kind of have to
apologize to you girls I know I do I put
you guys through until I saw all but
come through all the footage like
sometimes he 218 takes 24 it takes new
Christian sergeant but you said Jim
would do stuff on during your close-up
does that get a little annoying like
okay this is my close-up so because
there's a camera on him it's gonna be
like he's gonna be forced to do stuff
that takes the attention I think you're
not at all everybody everyone loved Jim
everybody knew that he was the whole
reason the movie is being made there's
no liar liar' without Jim Carrey I mean
and so you yes you like to be like able
to be like oh I want out of you Jim
Carrey too but you know there's only
room for one Jim Carrey in a movie you
cannot have everybody being Jim Carrey
so it it didn't bother me at all I was
just embarrassed because you know it's
well you know in that movie I think he
was making like 18 million dollars and
everybody else was making scale cuz
there's only room in the paycheck for
what you know but we were all incredibly
grateful that movie opens huge I think
it's the only movie I was ever in that
had a huge opening and it was very good
for my career would you're now like
pretty synonymous with the Chucky
franchise this is my fourth Chuckie
movie right which is amazing out today
let me do my little plug VOD and blu-ray
it's really hard for you to remember
because of blu-ray and VOD these are you
know a child or the seventies these are
like phrases that don't trip off the
tongue very easily I was remember
October 3rd but I got October 3rd on
video-on-demand and blu-ray but you know
the kids are all used to this is you
just have to go to the movies and see it
like I saw jaws in the theater yeah and
then all of a sudden like I don't know
if I'll ever see jaws again I saw yeah I
saw the movie last week in a fear oh my
god it's so great jaws no no but it's so
great on the light screen like I can't
imagine the jaws is that great on your
iPad so you know that's the sad thing is
a lot of movies they make this way to be
released directly cuz they they said
this is how people watch movies in fact
the movie I try to not mention this but
a lot of the Chucky movement the movies
have been pirated already people are
like yeah what do you mean it comes out
tomorrow I already watched her but of
course you know that you don't get the
actress you don't get the quality when I
went to I was filming a movie in
Bulgaria and we went to the premiere of
cold mountain cuz it had not Bulgaria
Romania yes that was a very good pirate
imitation I remember that's why it
didn't work out with us because you kept
going her during the sex act the
legion's
so yes in Romania there was a guy right
in front of me at the premiere with a
video camera and nobody was stopping him
and he was cheap filming the entire
movie I guess to you know release online
or something and he kept like adjusting
it making sure it worked and everything
I was like oh my god it premieres in LA
you never have a guy with a video blog
right front of you like filming the
movie for priority like hide it at least
if you're gonna do it at least try to be
don't think things that can detect that
now well he wasn't even trying to hide
it it was a giant camera this was like
15 years ago
he's like the cameras the size of a baby
in the the screen was glowing but you
know it's a Romania they're probably
used to people filming movies in the
movies and so like a lot of times you
see those pirated movies and like people
are getting up and leaving in the middle
of the film and stuff so it's really
better to get the you know the view see
the original yes yeah you can get it on
iTunes Store I got it on my Apple TV
alright so I watched it yesterday twice
did you really watch it yeah yeah
the oven I watched it I watched it
yesterday I watched curse of chucky and
then cult of Chucky back to back oh my
gosh you like this if Chucky so oh you
so oh you watch curse of chucky first
and yeah just so I could make sure that
I was in the right place I love that uh
because usually when you get to the
seventh incarnation of one of these
horror movie franchises they kind of
throw out the original yeah just start
doing random [ __ ] and it's just kind of
a mess and a and your becomes too campy
yeah and you're just watching it because
uh yeah I like the monster and bah bah
bah but I loved it like it feels like
the deeper this franchise goes the more
they go back to the original and like
draw out this story because like this
movie is really way more than any of the
other ones part of this bigger story
that lasts throughout all seven of them
great Don Mancini is a huge horror fan
and he's like Chucky's biggest fan
really he's been doing the Chucky movies
he wrote the first one thirty years ago
when he was right out of college and
he's written every single one and he's
directed the last three so he really
what knows how to give the fans what
they want and because he's a horror film
aficionado if you look at a lot of phil
chucky films is like amage is two other
films that have gone before and then he
loves like sort of like the little
inside jokes like in this movie not to
give me anything away there's like a
little tip of the hat to bound and you
know the last movie curse of chucky was
a little bit uh wait until dark and seed
of Chucky there's a little bit of Joan
Crawford in there's a birthday party
which is like the most wonderful
birthday party the Tiffany is throwing
for a child and Tiffany is you know just
like very you know gran-gran
you should wall didn't pronounce that
word right yes it's my favorite word but
I have to go on the greatest thing about
the internet now I can do a lot of words
because we didn't have TV we were
growing up and so I know all these words
but you never hear them in conversation
on the internet you can go on and you
say pronunciation there's somebody goes
grand shouldn't walk crowd chinois and I
repeat after them and they I try to
sprinkle in it the second greatest thing
on the internet that's not the greatest
thing on the Internet out here you know